[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg comme tous les
mois un député européen d'ile-de-france
nous accompagne durant cette émission
pour évoquer forcément à l'actualité
européenne ce soir patrick le hyaric et
vice président du groupe de la gauche
unitaire européenne membres en france du
parti communiste également directeur du
journal l'humanité notre invité ensemble
nous évoquerons notamment un rapport sur
un socle européen des droits sociaux
durant cette émission nous allons
également à découvrir l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'union européenne conrad
adenauer on parlera également d'égalité
homme-femme et vous découvrir les pays
où la parité est la plus respectée en
europe enfin les yvelinois auront la
parole dans cette émission puisque un
habitant de saint quentin en yvelines
posera une question directement à notre
invité via une tablette numérique
[Musique]
patrick le hyaric bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes du coup je le disais député
européen depuis 2009 membre de la
commission au parlement emploi et
affaires sociales engagées au sein du
parti communiste français depuis les
années 80 c'est ce qui est inscrit en
tout cas sur votre site internet vous
avez été notamment conseiller municipal
de lorient et de la courneuve directeur
aussi du journal l'humanité depuis l'an
2000 dans quel costume d'ailleurs êtes
vous le plus à l'aise aujourd'hui celui
du politique ou celui du journaliste or
il n'ya pas de costume c'est le je suis
un c'est tout il n'y a pas de préférence
pour vous il n'ya pas peut-être un on va
dire une fonction dans laquelle vous
vous amusez le plus où vous correspond
le plus si vous aimez faire un choix
imaginons moi je m'amuse pas moi je
milite aussi au service des gens
j'essaye de faire pour le mieux
j'ai été en responsabilité à l'humanité
dans des conditions particulières mais
c'est l'information le débat
démocratique c'est un travail
extrêmement intéressant il ya beaucoup
de dents jeu et beaucoup de plaisir
aussi faire vivre à développer
l'humanité et tenter de mettre à la
disposition de nos concitoyens
décryptage un petit peu différent de
l'actualité de ce qu'on connaît par
ailleurs d'ailleurs très rapidement
est-ce que c'est difficile de combiner
les deux fonctions est ce que vous y
arrivez tous les jours et ce qu'on doit
prendre un certain rythme peut-être au
début en 2009 2010 il faut un petit
rythme de travail mais il faut
travailler
patrick le hyaric j'imagine que vous
êtes sensibles est intéressé par
l'histoire européenne dans cette
émission nous découvrons le parcours des
pères fondateurs aujourd'hui philippe le
guen au directeur de l'association jean
monnet basée dans les yvelines nous
présente conrad adenauer qui fut
notamment en septembre 1949 le premier
chancelier de la république fédérale
d'allemagne
à
[Musique]
conrad adenauer c'était un homme
politique allemand qui au début du 20e
siècle
avant la première guerre mondiale a été
le plus jeune maire d'une ville
importante d'allemagne cologne c'est un
homme du rhin il se définissait lui-même
comme un rhénan donc l'esprit rhénan
c'est aussi l'esprit tourné vers vers
les autres c'est un chrétien qui avait
des valeurs chrétiennes assez fort et
puis c'est aussi quelqu'un qui était
très respecté en allemagne très
pacifiste qui avait été emprisonné par
la gestapo pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et qui à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale a pris la tête du
nouveau parti donc des chrétiens
démocrates allemands et qui est devenu
ensuite chancelier donc on parle même en
allemagne de l'ère du chancelier
adenauer qui est dans une période très
difficile après guerre où l'allemagne
était occupé par les alliés et où la
guerre froide aussi évidemment se jouait
sur le territoire allemand
il a eu un rôle très important et puis
l'a soutenu et porté aussi le projet que
le présentait les français de communauté
du charbon et de l'acier l'idée de jean
monnet c'est de partir de
la france et de l'allemagne qui se sont
fait la guerre pendant des siècles pour
construire cette paix sur le tout le
continent européen donc il fallait
évidemment que le les allemands en
particulier le chef d'état le chancelier
non seulement approuvent mais sois
persuadé que ce projet était était le
bon et adenauer a tout de suite compris
l'opportunité extraordinaire qu'il était
fait à l'allemagne 2 après la 2e guerre
mondiale de ne pas faire comme après la
première de ne pas humilier l'allemagne
vaincue par des réparations excessif par
l'occupation de son territoire dans la
confiscation de ses richesses
mais bien au contraire de mettre à
égalité les richesses principal qui
était le charbon et l'acier donc ça
l'est conrad adenauer a vraiment réussi
à convaincre l'opinion publique
allemande qu'il fallait que suivre ce
projet que c'était le bon projet pour
l'allemagne et pour créer la paix sur le
continent européen
l'unité de l'europe était un rêve pour
quelques-uns elle devint l'espoir de
beaucoup elle est aujourd'hui une
nécessité pour nous tous
[Musique]
l'histoire s'écrit aussi en ce moment
patrick le hyaric au parlement européen
avec l'élection d'un nouveau président
pour l'institution un président qui
succède au socialiste allemand martin
schultz quel bilan vous tirez vous de
ces cinq années de mandat pour martin
schultz il a il a tenté et réussi
vraisemblablement à faire vivre le
parlement européen
à côté d'autres institutions européennes
mais une chose est que lui ait pu être
plus présent qui est vraisemblement à
puce pu faire valoir parfois des idées
des orientations du parlement européen
autre chose et le pouvoir réel du
parlement européen car là il y a
toujours une difficulté c'est que le
parlement européen n'a pas le pouvoir
d'initiative législative le pouvoir le
parlement européen ne des bacs à partir
de directives c'est à dire l'équivalent
de loi qui lui sont proposés par la
commission est censée la faute de martin
schultz
il aurait pu jouer là-dessus non mais
moi moi je ne dis pas que c'est sa faute
moi je dis que la question fondamentale
n'est pas les hommes la question
fondamentale c'est que nous sommes un
parlement nous sommes une institution
démocratique élu directement par nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens
et si on le veut un fonctionnement
réellement démocratique il faut d'abord
plus les consulter et d'autres pas que
ce qu'il représente directement et
pouvoir d'initiative les jus des ti les
pouvoirs simplement foncer tout de même
avec le traité de lisbonne en 2000 ya un
pouvoir de ça doit aller plus loin
aujourd'hui un sûr il ya un pouvoir de
co législation mais ce n'est pas le
parlement européen qui met sur la table
un projet de législation et ça selon
vous dans le temps c'est une idée qui
peut éventuellement faire son chemin le
parlement européen est amené selon vous
dans les années à venir apprendre encore
plus de poids dans les institutions
européennes le mouvement
oh pas de vos collègues des dirigeants
des décideurs politiques le sait les
citoyens qui vont décider c'est pas les
gens qui sont ici qui vont décider ce
sont les citoyens qui vont et qui
doivent décider parce que si la
construction européenne n'est pas plus
démocratique et si son but n'est pas
plus de démocratie et de possibilité
pour les citoyens européens de coûts
construire un projet européen nouveau
celui qui est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui va
se briser
alors avec l'élection d'un nouveau
président au parlement européen une
autre question se pose c'est celle de la
grande coalition martin schulz en
étaient à un grand défendeur alors la
grande coalition pour expliquer ce que
c'est c'est un peu comme au parlement
allemand c'est les deux grands partis
ppe la droite et les socialistes la
gauche qui s'entendent sur les grands
sujets qui se mettent d'accord pour
payer de blocage on se pose la question
est-ce qu'il faut continuer avec ce
système là au parlement européen quel
est votre point de vue à vous à mon
point de vue c'est qu'il faut briser sa
d'urgence c'est que l'idée de grande
coalition c'est à dire que des gens se
succèdent dans les responsabilités
alternativement la droite que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et le parti
social démocrate européen le groupe de
la gauche des sociaux démocrates
ça c'est une idée mortifère parce que
c'est ce que nous venons de vivre
c'est-à-dire des compromis en permanence
mais ce ne sont pas des compromis
favorable au peuple en général ce sont
des compromis défavorable au peuple
c'est cette grande coalition qui impose
l'austérité c'est cette grande coalition
qui fait ce traité européen qui
acceptent le traité budgétaire européen
qui nous a mis dans la situation que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui donc il
faut sortir de là et mieux vaudrait
imaginer un bloc progressistes et
écologistes nouveau qui permet de mettre
en oeuvre en tout cas de faire
contre-pouvoir par rapport à la
commission et au conseil pour des
orientations progressiste et écologique
le blog dont vous parlez comprendrait
quel parti au centre du tableau des
partis qu'on ne connaît pas d'ailleurs
très bien évidemment le riz et les
socialistes le gouvernement le groupe
socialiste le groupe de la gauche
unitaire européenne
votre double
oui le groupe des écologistes et puis il
ya sur certains sujets peut-être pas sur
tous mais une partie des groupes qu'on
appelle les libéraux qui sur un certains
centristes en résumé angola il y en a
une partie qui sur des sujets peut-être
pas sur tous les sujets économiques mais
sur des sujets de société notamment nous
permettrait de faire avancer un certain
nombre d'orientations
l'autre actualité en ce moment c'est
forcément le break site la première
ministre britannique theresa may a dit
qu'elle souhaitait un brick site en gros
en vue ont là aussi on voulait y aller
ce clair et net
vous êtes partisan de quelle position
vous vis-à-vis de la grande-bretagne est
ce que vous êtes pour ce qu'on appelle
un arbre éxiste ou plutôt un soft
briques site que les choses il fasse en
douceur ni l'un ni l'autre moi je suis
pour respecter le vote des britanniques
je le regrette je regrette surtout les
bases sur lequel il s'est fait parce que
il ya à la fois un rejet de la
construction européenne telle qu'elle se
fait mais il ya aussi un certain nombre
de relents de rejet de l'autre
c'est dans une sorte de l'union
européenne pour encore plus de
libéralisme c'est ce qu'ils disent est
pas exactement
exactement et donc je ne pense pas que
pour le peuple britanniques pour les
travailleurs britanniques ce soit une
bonne décision mais maintenant je suis
pour le respecter mais le monde de la
finance le monde des affaires en grande
bretagne ne peut pas avoir l'argent du
beurre et le beurre lui-même parce que
il faut qu'il choisisse on peut pas
faire en grande bretagne un paradis
fiscal
en concurrence avec les autres pays
européens
on ne peut pas continuer à faire cette
grande city au détriment des droits des
travailleurs dans l'ensemble
de l'europe pas de l'union européenne
mais de l'europe y compris donc la
grande bretagne est ce que au sein des
institutions européennes et notamment du
parlement européen il ya un sentiment de
vengeance parfois qui se diffuse par
rapport aux aux autorités britanniques
avec cette volonté de vouloir un arbre
excite ou alors finalement n'ont répondu
que ça non je ne crois pas je crois
qu'il ya plutôt une incompréhension
malheureusement il ya beaucoup
d'incompréhension sur ce qui s'est passé
il n'y a pas la volonté aujourd'hui de
lancer un projet de refondation à partir
des besoins des populations et c'est un
peu ça le drame que nous sommes en train
de vivre
est ce que comme donald trump le nouveau
président américain vous pensez que
d'autres pays pourraient sortir de
l'union européenne je ne sais pas et je
ne crois pas parce que
évidemment peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on
commence en grande-bretagne à mieux
mesurer la bêtise qui a été fait parce
que si on ne reste pas ensemble pour
tenter de transformer la construction
européenne
aujourd'hui si on se divise évidemment
on se trouvera affaibli vis-à-vis des
etats-unis le les milieux d'affaires
nord américain représenté par monsieur
tram attendent que ça attendre que
l'union européenne se cassent évidemment
ce serait un bloc de moins alors qu'il
est en train de créer des alliances
ailleurs tout en attaquant la chine par
exemple est beaucoup un présent un
rapport de votre commission votre
commission c'est celle de l'emploi et
des affaires sociales un rapport du
socialiste député européen portugais
maria rodrigues celui-ci se penche sur
la mise en place d'un socle européen des
droits sociaux
c'est un très long rapport assez
complexe mais bien définis qu'on peut
trouver d'ailleurs sur le site internet
du parlement européen
patrick le hyaric expliqué nous quand on
évoque un socle européen des droits
sociaux on parle de quoi précisément de
quel droit parle-t-on beaucoup de droit
j'ai le droit des droits d'égalité
hommes femmes il ya des droits en ce qui
concerne ça peut être par exemple les
réserves de travail rémunération des
heures de travail les rémunèrent
conditions travail la sécurité sociale
le temps de le temps de travail bien que
là dans le rapport il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'évolution mais il ya un certain nombre
de choses dans le rapport qui sont
positifs il ya eu mille cent un peu plus
de 1100 amendement il y aura des
compromis auquel nous participons
nous mêmes il y à la demande de
reconnaître la charte des droits
fondamentaux
mais évidemment un rapport ne suffit pas
il faut des actes concrets
c'est à dire il faut partout maintenant
augmenter les rémunérations du travail
et aller vers un minimum dans chaque
pays européen à avoir la concurrence que
nous avons aujourd'hui justement l'idée
c'est d'avoir un minimum sur l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne pour
effacer les relais concurrence parfois
déloyale selon les différents pays oui
il ya des distorsions on ne peut pas
accepter aujourd'hui qui a des salaires
à 150 euros en roumanie
quand notre smic a noué plus élevé celui
du luxembourg encore plus élevé c'est à
dire qu'il y aurait un compromis entre
les deux c'est spécialement pour les
français ça pourrait être vers le bas
non ça ne peut pas être ça qu'il faut
trouver un système qui monte tout le
monde avec une progression évidemment
plus rapide pour ceux qui sont le plus
bas c'est à dire la question c'est que
il faut sortir de la concurrence entre
salariés de la mise en concurrence le
des salariés entre eux c'est ça qui sert
essentiellement à délocaliser les
entreprises et qui sert les profits mais
ça ça va contre les salaires parce que
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on ne fasse pas
ça la pression elle elle est sûre les
plus haut vers le bas et c'est un
argument pour les gouvernements et puis
le patronat en france pour ne pas
augmenter les rémunérations par exemple
ici on a du mal à imaginer quand même
que ça puisse se faire à court terme un
tel projet est ce que là on est à des
décennies de des décennies comment un
salaire de 150 euros en roumanie
pourrait rattraper aussi rapidement à
salaire comme celui du smic français qui
est au dessus du milieu des roses
ben c'est à dire il faut il faut
plusieurs dispositions c'est que d'abord
à travail égal salaire égal c'est à dire
une entreprise européenne devraient
payer de la même manière son salarié
français le salarié portugais et
espagnols
ces travailleurs détachés aussi rentrer
oui oui ça c'est un ca d'autres volets
autre sujet si on veut mais ça une
toutes les entreprises doivent payer les
salariés ou qu'ils soient de la même
manière sinon on aura toujours ce
principe de concurrence et évidemment
pour cela il faut des fonds structurels
européens pour aider là où c'est
nécessaire il faut l'utilisation autres
du crédit européen par exemple la banque
centrale européenne elle fabrique des
des millions d'euros chaque mois elle va
avoir mis mille elle à milan division
même barre des 1000 ya 1200 milliards
d'euros en création monétaire qui n'ont
servi qu'aux banques est bien mieux vaut
à aider les entreprises qui s'engagent à
augmenter progressivement les
rémunérations des salariés à en mettre à
en formation lorsqu'un essai nécessaire
maintienne l'emploi que de donner de
l'argent aux banques pour la spéculation
financière et il y a il ya ces fonds
européens
et il ya les profits des entreprises de
même il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
possibles si on en avait la volonté mais
il faut légiférer eu une telle
initiative de tels droits un tel socle
européen à ce que ça profiterait aussi
excusez-moi de revient dessus mais
principalement aux pays les plus pauvres
c'est à dire aux pays de l'est est
peut-être moins aux allemands ou
français aux italiens les plus riches de
l'union européenne qui voudrait dire que
le rapport n'a pas d'intérêt les plus
riches de l'union européenne
ça peut se lire de deux manières ça peut
se lire de la manière classique mais ça
peut se lire aussi du point de vue de la
vie des gens quand vous avez 16 millions
de personnes en france qui termine le
mois à 5 euros près quand vous avez 9
millions de pauvres la question de la
richesse et leur relative la richesse
malheureusement elle cette lutte in à un
pool de la société alors que ceux qui
travaillent ou ceux qui sont privés
travaillent eux ils sont de plus en plus
en difficulté
donc c'est cette c'est l'ensemble qu'il
faut faire monter en combattant le
travail précaire en combattant les jobs
à 0 d'ailleurs le le rapport se prononce
contre les jobs à zéro euro qu'on a
inventé au royaume uni et en italie
récemment de ce point de vue il y a des
choses positives mais il faudra des
actes intervenir dans le domaine social
et - peut-être dans le domaine
économique est ce que c'est un débouché
finalement qui va permettre à l'union
européenne de de se rattacher un peu à
ses citoyens de recréer un lien affectif
entre ben oui enfin c'est ce que c'est
aussi ça le l'objet d'un tel rapport
c'est de dire voilà l'europe intervient
aussi sur d'autres domaines que ceux qui
peuvent vous éloignez belle on nous dit
on nous dit toujours il ya une union
économique et monétaire mais il faudrait
une union sociale la question qui est
posée aujourd'hui c'est une union
sociale et une union écologique une
union environnementale qui soit du côté
de la transition environnementale parce
que de ce côté là il y à des millions et
des millions d'emplois et des millions
de gens de jeunes à mettre en formation
pour l'économie de demain
et donc si on ne prend pas ça à bras le
corps il n'y a pas d'avenir et vous avez
raison il n'ya pas d'union qui puisse
tenir tant qu'on ne parlera que d'argent
que de banques centrales de taux de
parité et pas des droits sociaux des
individus et des droits humains
forcément notre discussion en ce moment
ce serait faire un peu un débat qui
évolue beaucoup en france et notamment
dans la primaire de la gauche et celle
d'un revenu universel pour aller jusqu'à
800 euros par mois pour sans condition
qui serait versée à tout le monde
certains candidats défendent notamment
benoît hamon député des yvelines
vous en pensez quoi vous cette idée du
revenu universel est ce que ça va dans
le sens de ce rapport est ce que c'est
une bonne initiative à un revenu
universel c'est l'apparence d'une bonne
idée mais moi d'abord je crois au
travail et je crois à la rémunération
juste du travail quand la semaine
dernière on a appris que les entreprises
cotées en bourse les 40 entreprises
cotées en bourse qu'on appelle les
entreprises du cac 40 vont verser 56
milliards d'euros de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
eh bien on voit bien qu'il y a de
l'argent pour augmenter la rémunération
du travail et donc il ne non seulement
il ne faut pas supprimer les allocations
qui existe aujourd'hui
il faudrait les augmenter mais le revenu
universel tel qu'il est pensé ici
exonère totalement le ceux qui font des
profits sur le travail des salariés de
leurs responsabilités en matière de
salaires concrètement une seule question
encore sur sur la présidentielle
française vous trouvez qu'on parle assez
d'europe où est-ce qu'on en parle bien
de l'europe dans cette dans ce début de
campagne
c'est pas la question qu'on parle assez
ou pas assez c'est que en gros on en a
peut-être mal
nous avons nous avons une campagne
où on va on va avoir le choix entre le
moins pire et le pire donc on ne peut
pas avoir une campagne comme ça quand on
est dans la situation mondiale que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui la situation de
la france une situation de crise et même
la situation européenne le un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
il doit proposer un dessin un projet
nouveau et il doit avoir un débat sur ce
projet nouveau et ce projet nouveau doit
porter sur le développement humain et
doit porter sur le progrès écologique
d'ailleurs sur sur cette campagne vous
vous êtes un soutien de jean-luc
mélenchon
oui je soutiens jean luc mélenchon oui
malgré les problèmes qu'il peut y avoir
pour les élections législatives avec le
parti il y adeux il y a des problèmes
avec lui c'est bien dommage
moi je crois que il faut revenir à la
raison et il faut créer les conditions
de l'unité la plus large de telle sorte
que lui même jean luc mélenchon hippies
bousculer sérieusement la donne en ayant
le score le plus élevé possible
et d'autre part il faut une autre
majorité au parlement
et pour avoir une autre majorité au
parlement il ne faut pas se diviser
comme aujourd'hui on en vient maintenant
à notre rubrique et chez nos voisins à
ça se passe comment aujourd'hui zoom sur
la place des femmes dirigeantes dans
l'union européenne les précisions avec
olivier jeune vice responsable du centre
d'information europe direct à saint
germain en laye
[Musique]
les femmes sont moins présentes dans
l'égout dans les gouvernements
alors ça dépend après des pays mais
généralement on tourne dans des
pourcentages entre 30 et 40 % de
présence de femmes dans les digues dans
les différents gouvernements
sachant que après il ya des pays où les
femmes ne sont absolument pas présente
dans les gouvernements c'est notamment
le cas du gouvernement hongrois en
l'union européenne influence
nationalement et localement la présence
des femmes en politique alors tout
simplement via un fort volet législatif
concernant notamment ce qui est ce qu'on
appelle la non discrimination
donc le fait de ne pas discriminer des
femmes par rapport aux hommes notamment
sur la question des salaires du
traitement des femmes que voilà du
traitement des femmes
après l'union européenne a aussi incité
certains états notamment mettre en place
des politiques de sensibilisation
concernant l'égalité des femmes
notamment en matière de politique et
c'est notamment le cas de la grèce
l'union européenne montre l'exemple en
matière de responsabilité concernant les
femmes en politique si on prend le cas
de la commission européenne on a
plusieurs
on a plusieurs portefeuilles très
important voire on peut dire régalien
qui sont attribués qui sont attribués à
des femmes
on a notamment par exemple les affaires
étrangères qui sont attribués à
l'italienne federica mot guérini autre
portefeuille non régaliens mais qui là
ont une importance très particulière au
niveau européen la concurrence qui est
attribuée donc à margrethe vestage
guerre et aussi notamment tout ce qui
est par exemple le portefeuille du
commerce donc notamment la négociation
des codes des traités internationaux qui
là sont dédiés à cecilia malmstrom 1
[Musique]
cette émission se veut aussi interactive
leur fait souvent l'objet de reproches
trop complexe pas assez transparents
voire inutiles et bien nous donnons la
parole à des acteurs de la vie locale et
aux habitants aussi des civils c'est à
ce moment là qu'on se sert de la
tablette écoutez la question posée par
un habitant de saint quentin en yvelines
alesi cliquez sur sur la tablette
patrick le hyaric
bonjour je m'appelle lycée monsoreau
j'habite voisins-le-bretonneux et la
question qui vous est posée aux députés
c est ce que la commission européenne ne
peut pas laisser plus de liberté aux
états membres
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets qui
sont traités qui pourrait dès
décentralisée en fait la question ce
porte sur la commission européenne mais
ça peut être la vérité pour roland sont
des institutions européennes est ce
qu'il faut plus de liberté pour les
détails moins d'interventions à des
institutions vous en pensez-quoi très
rapide où l'on veut d'abord les
décisions principales sont prises au
conseil européen et c'est une table le
conseil européen où il ya tous les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement donc la
question est totalement légitime mais la
commission ne fait qu'obéir aux conseils
en vérité c'est à dire aux chefs d'état
et de gouvernement donc la question
fondamentale elle est de savoir quelle
politique on met en oeuvre si c'est une
politique pour les gens ou si c'est une
politique pour les forces de l'argent
merci patrick le hyaric d'avoir
participé à ce seuil et 8 politique
version europe je rappelle que vous êtes
vice président du groupe de la gauche
unitaire européenne ici au parlement
européen membre aussi du parti
communiste français directeur de
l'humanité
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
replay sur tv fil 78 points com ou sur
l'application tv fil 78 prochain numéro
du 7-8 politique dans deux semaines
[Musique]
à
e